When I look at an existing market, it's clear that if you've match those market needs,
you could be achieving profitability the soonest.
If you're doing a clone market--that is copying a US business model in a foreign country,
that probably is the second closest to immediate profitability because you know the market exist
that you just need to implement it in your local country.
Resegmented market--well, that's probably somewhere in between existing in clone and new
because you not only have to understand the market you have to understand
the customer's specific needs or low-cost needs.
But the longest time to profitability is a new market.
You have a vision that you understand what the future might look like, but the market
just hasn't adapted yet and that might take years.